♪
- On ne peut pas se tromper.
Le village qu'on chercheesesese.
Il est partout, beau, je
souriant, comme un grand sage
qui veille sur la villoù il esù.
La maison de son enfance
Tamara Filatova ne se lasse
jamais de faire visiter.
Elle est la mieux placée,
son oncle préféré.
Elle nous raconte le jour où
il s'est envolé dans le cosmos
à 14 ans, en classe,
un matin ensoleillé.
(en russe)
À l'époque, l'espace était
comme un trou noir béant
qui pouvait nous avaler.
Mais quand le régime a annoncé
qu'il était revenu sain et sauf
après 108 minutes de vol,t t t .
homme dans l'espace était
un des nôtres!"u u u u u u u u ,
un homme ordinaire comme
il y en a des millions
en URSS", disait Gagarineetetet.
"De simple fils de menui
à star mondiale, le premier
cosmonaute devient ldededededede
de propagande de
de l'Union soviétique.
Reçu en héro
ambassadeur du modèle soviétique
en pleine e"e"e"e"e"e"e",
dit l'historien Alexander
Zhelezny
"Mais il était exceptionnel
pour l'humanité ne p
jamais être contesté.
Sa personne demeur
brillante, grande, séduisante."
♪ ♪ ♪
60 ans plus tard, il est
un des rares dont la légen
est intacte. Les Russes
l'adorent, toutes générations
rebaptisée Gagarine, voue
un culte inégalé à tout
♪ ♪
C'était jour de fête quand nous
"Les plus grands symboles
de notre pays sont encore
15 ans, qui danse pour
les invités. Parmi eux,
de cosmonautes que Gagarine
a inspirées, y compris
qu'on appelle aussi
"le dernier Soviétique",
puisqu'il était quququququququq.
"Mais l'expl
ce qu'il a fait, va au-delà
de l'URSS
dit le cosmonaute.
♪
Reste qu'aujourd'hui, son vol
myth
pour le Kremlin et sa politique
deRuRuRuRuRuRuRuRuRussie.
"Gagarine a été, est et sera
même si le programme spatialt ti
de l'URSS qui a propulsé
- Et je crois qu'on ne peu
séparer l'histoire de l'ère
soviétique et l'histoireieieiei.
- La Russie se définit
par ses gloires du passé,
dit Vladimir Ivanogagagagagagag,
c'est un exemp
extraordinaire.- Et comme tant ,
sa fin
Gagarine meurt à 34 ans
en p
sans jamais avoir remis
e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.e.fafafafafr
le cosmonaute numéro 1",
Youri rêvait au cosmos,lelelele.
Comme on disait à l'époque
son courage et son charisme,
son symbole de la jeunesse
éternelle.
Gagarine est immorte